[Musique]
on se retrouve aujourd'hui au parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse à choisel en fond de vallée de
choisel en compagnie de stéphane loriot
qui est animateur patrimoine au pnr
bonjour bonjour alors souvenez vous on
vous avait déjà montré des plantes
comestibles sauvage en hiver et alors
avec cette sécheresse ici on est est ce
qu'on peut quand même trouver des
plantes dans mon jardin c'est déjà très
compliquée sur les plateaux en plein
cagnard ça devient de plus en plus
compliquées alors que ici en fond de
vallée bas les zones sombres est fraîche
millions remis lumière donc on ici nous
avons quatre plantes vraiment un vocable
quasiment quasiment voilà pour tout
l'été en fête et on va aller voir ça
tout de suite
[Musique]
bon
et
oh
on va commencer par parler god cette
plante se récolte quasiment toute
l'année là vous avez des jeunes pousses
excellent mélange en salade et là vous
avez des feuilles plus plus âgés ont
velouté en soupant gratin c'est
absolument remarquable riche en
protéines un peu moins que leur team est
très très nourrissante et avec cet
avantage avoir une amertume moindre donc
c'est une plante savoureuse peu amer
très nourrissante et qui vous nettoie le
corps le voilà c'est une plante dur
éthique dépuratives je vous propose le
sentiment cette odeur subtile mais pour
autant puissante
et oui
c'est presque poivrer supinfo oui on va
aller voir la deuxième plainte très bien
c'est parti c'est parti
[Musique]
alors ne pas évoquer le pissenlit c'est
difficile c'est la plus connue en termes
de plantes sauvages comestibles en salam
notamment dès que le fai sont belles on
va dire on peut les manger quasiment
toute l'année aussi donc là en mélange
avec du concombre comme d'habitude
excellent et puis si l'amertume vous
gêne pour les spas les débutants on va
dire ben vous accusez la plante tout
simplement elle contient vous voir plus
de protéines de provitamine à que la
carotte donc pour préserver pour avoir
une peau en pleine santé c'est tout à
fait un tout tout à fait indiquée et du
coup quelles sont les règles d'or de
l'accueil est bon alors d'abord évitons
les sur cueillette ça mais avec nos
quatre plantes évoqué aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas donc on peut vraiment
les accueillir de manière abondante sans
nuire à la ressource ensuite on ne
cueille pas aux abords des monocultures
avec des intrants chimiques dans les
endroits très fréquentés avec des
passages de chiens évidemment c'était
assez à proscrire et puis pour le reste
franchement c'est à vous de repérer les
endroits qui nous semble propre alors
nous avons cette sortie avec des jeunes
repoussent protéines foliaire en
puissance vous avez les visaient ses
amis n'est que la viande n'a pas
forcément le calcium vitamine c le faire
tout est là me micronutriments cette
plante est un véritable cadeau petit
exemple et les racines de leur tee sont
excellentes pour éviter aux jeunes
enfants de faire pipi au lit parce que
ça resserre les seringues terre comment
les attrape parce que ça comme un
pouvoir urticant c'est fort lortie
sa réputation est faite donc donc quand
jean accueille en grande quantité je
prône de faire de grands cuir avec une
paire de ciseaux comme ça c'est plus
c'est plus facile quand je que quelques
brins on peut faire ce geste là déjà je
prends la quiche par en dessous et
lorsque le car et si la plante du bas
vers le haut comme ceux ci il sera une
pousse vers le haut pour éviter des
prédations donc là vous ne serez pas
appliquée vous allez à linverse dix
répliques et de fête
[Musique]
il est difficile de ne pas évoquer la
berceuse commune le nom latin est
évocateur heracleum siphon guillaume
force des reculs vertèbres de la colonne
vertébrale donc blanc tu vraiment très
robuste une plante tonique qui a plein
de vertus médicinales évidemment là nous
sommes au coeur de l'été ce sont les
fruits et qui se forme en ce moment
qu'ils sont vraiment vraiment
intéressante les fruits et une saveurs
d'agrumes qui quand ça se rapproche du
piment et comme plan de condiments avec
des plats salés ou sucrés c'est
remarquable vous allez comprendre la
puissance
de cette odeur
sa boîte
c'est un clémentine ouais c'est frais
c'est associer un peu à la fleur
d'oranger par exemple par exemple
[Musique]
un
merci stéphane pour tous ces conseils
ces informations sur ces quatre plantes
que moi je connaissais pas très bien en
tout cas voire pour certaines pas du
tout et dernière petite question est ce
que vous auriez peut-être une recette de
cuisine pour cuisiner ces plantes alors
concernant les god et leur fille
notamment la recette est la même je
j'appelle ça le velouté donc c'est une
recette basse et une soupe mais qui ne
contient pas ni de pommes de terre ni de
crème fraîche 90 à 95% et c'est l'huile
d'olive qui fera qui offrait à ce côté
onctueux et pas merci moi ça m'a donné
enfin parce que je vais aller préparer
tout ça et puis je pense qu'on se
retrouvera en automne pour d'autres
conseils volontiers volontiers